as you may have noticed larry elder is
running for governor of california in
the recall election so he's walking
through some neighborhood in california
and a
lady in a gorilla mask throws an egg at
him you see larry walking down
he's walking then there we go
white lady in a gorilla mask
throws an egg at him she's on a bike
a beautiful place
then another kooky guy and then they're
throwing more stuff
so then they put they put larry in the
car they drive away
this is like a campaign commercial for
larry elder here here's california under
new some elect literally anybody else
i gotta tell you about my meat you know
how much i love good ranchers all right
this is good american meat did you know
that over 80 of the grass-fed beef sold
in america is imported from overseas
that is why i get my meat from
goodranchers.com their product is 100
american when you buy your steak and
chicken from good ranchers not only are
you getting amazing meat but you're also
supporting american farms by working
together with local farms and ranches
and shipping straight to your door
goodranchers.com is a safe and
convenient way
to order your meat save you money get
great meat help the american farmer i
love their stuff especially their
burgers i think are magnificent go check
it out right now go to goodranchers.com
to buy now or subscribe today and save
20 on each box of mouthwatering meats
subscribing brings the cost down to less
than five dollars a meal plus right now
get an additional 20 bucks off and free
express shipping if you go to
granters.com knowles or use code knowles
at checkout 20 off and free express
shipping at goodranchers.com
know where your meat comes from with
goodranchers.com
knowles
a white lib she seemed white i don't
know if she's white or hispanic or so
she seemed kind of
uh a lib in a gorilla mask just threw
some an egg at larry elder larry elder
you see
is the black face of white supremacy
that's
that's the line from the la times and uh
it you know he's not just a sort of
amiable libertarian black guy from south
central no he's the far right radical
white supremacist black guy and that's
why political violence is justified to
stop him that's what that's what the
left is implying and that's what they're
perpetrating against him right now
i'm not even going to say it you know
you know what every
reaction to this is well
well if the rules were reversed if the
situation were reversed yeah we all know
that we know the problem here is
that
the hypothetical doesn't do us any good
we know that there are different
standards here
i mean they're willing to call
larry elder a white supremacist the the
positive takeaway from this should be
when they call you a racist just who
cares who cares it doesn't mean anything
don't let it get to you man wear it as a
badge of honor to be called a racist by
some dishonest idiot lib where it's a it
means you've won the argument
means they fear you and they fear larry
elder
[Music]
[Music]